[Music]
Hellboy was always a character that I
was a bit hit and miss about whilst he
seemed cool in design and concept and
the films had some excellent will
building in them I just felt like they
lacked a certain something to take the
character out of the c-list position and
into a main movie star after Hellboy 2
there were several rumors of a trilogy
but since nothing ever came to fruition
it seemed like the character would fall
into obscurity until images of David
Harbor in the role appeared last year
today we got our first look at the film
and I'm not exactly sure how I feel
about it firstly this is a complete 180
in tone compared to the Gilmore del Toro
films and when I saw the characters step
out of the police van cracking jokes was
pretty shocked to see the new direction
by the trailers end I did kind of settle
into it but I can imagine that this will
rob a lot of fans the wrong way it's
very clear that this is heavily
influenced by Deadpool but almost to the
point that it seems to miss what made
Hellboy well
Hellboy this has the same kind of feel
to it as the Ghostbuster rebooted and it
just seems slightly over-the-top to me
right now I had heard a couple of months
ago that screenings of the film had
received dismal receptions or really
wondered how when on paper the character
and franchise had a lot of things going
for it
in execution however I can see how
people may think that they got it wrong
when we've had excellent trailers for
both Captain Marvel and Avengers and
game this month this just seems like it
dirt and hasn't really won me round just
yet obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the trailer and if you think
I'm wrong so make sure you leave a
comment saying why if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of the recent DC Titans
Batman plot synopsis which will be
linked at the end of this one this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]